hi welcome to another episode of my
let's play and remember when I said last
time that I would have to do something
about that wing Rider because I was
being me and of course the comment
section was going apeshit and yeah I was
being an idiot and welcome to my life
and all that you know the deal as so I
forgot that I was working on a wing
Rider and I built that tunnel that a
wing rider wouldn't fit through so I've
decided to get rid of the wing rider and
just make it an intimate blitz or not an
internment bliss and intamin LSM or
whatever you kids call those things
these days you know the drill so that's
what's going on right now so this is not
a wing runner anymore wing rider is rip
it's now an intermediate now an intimate
Ellison
I hope you want to keep oh okay this is
how terrible I am at coasters [ __ ] so
basically it's this one intamin coaster
with our box track or something that
looks pretty swell and it's pretty fast
and and stuff and it does curves and I'm
going to add tsunami
that's basically my train of thought at
this point at this point though I am
doing these supports right now and I
think I promised last time that I would
actually work on the foliage for the
invert once but yeah I kind of been
procrastinating that because we've done
you know foliage on the on that invert
and I didn't really feel like doing it
and I did feel like working on the
scenery and supports of this ride so I
just decided to go for that because this
is just kind of like well I don't know
why but I just wanted to get this done
basically and that's why I'm working on
this so and it's pretty funny because
it's actually when I recorded my
tutorial well both of my tutorials and I
actually showed my chrome theme and
people like oh yes the eeveelutions and
all that and it's it's basically if you
haven't seen that I have a chrome theme
with evolutions with being Floyd the
Dark Side of the Moon album cover and
it's kind of a mashup and a parody sort
of and it's really cool and I like it
and people actually sad that someone had
it on a shirt and I was like that's a
good idea
I might actually print it but also I
decided to just listened to Pink Floyd
while playing roller coaster kin 3 today
and I must say it was actually pretty
good like it kind of works as a working
music because you don't really
one or at least I don't want my music to
be too distracting or too catchy papi
kind of stuff
I also don't really like to listen to
electronic dance music when playing or
like I sing in three so I figured that
Mozart was actually a nice thing to
listen to but symphonic metal and rock
were also very successful but yeah Pink
Floyd works as well so yeah I just keep
experimenting and life is good so that's
basically what's going on when it comes
to that but that's not really that
important because of course you guys
can't hear that and I'm glad that I
turned off my son because I don't want
to listen to being Floyd at sixteen
times the speed because of the time
lapse now these supports I think are
somewhat intimate ish the only problem
with instrument supports that I have is
that I just don't have enough experience
with them I kind of don't really know
how to place everything I figured they
would just be like bnm in a sense except
they would be wider and they do have
cross beams but I think that I'm still
better at being AM supports than
anything else but at that point I
figured okay I've done enough supports
for today I'm just going to run the
layout and see what the speed is like
speed is okay and let's work on some
castles because I haven't worked on a
nice little castle in a very long time
and they're always fun to work on
so I figure might as well now the game
did crash like twice or even three times
when I was building this so that wasn't
well that wasn't very great but it's not
that huge of a deal at least I was a
[ __ ] Savior I thought at one point
that I lost everything but apparently
I'm just such a [ __ ] Savior that I
even saved without actually knowing it
so I didn't lose as much as I thought I
would have so that's cool and as you
might see and recognize this little gate
over here is very similar to the gate
that I have on the little tunnel and I
know why I just decided to kind of keep
that as a recurring theme but build
around this one with the castle and all
that to actually make it look very
different and really this is all just
experimentation on the well when it
comes to this because I've never really
done a theme like this I've never really
worked with these scents before
really I'm very new to this as well so I
don't know if I can say too much about
that it's just a usual Cottle [ __ ] just
building loads of sours and then calling
it a castle because that's pretty much
how it works though that's that's
probably oversimplifying it but yeah my
plan with this is to just add as many
buildings as I can on this and just make
a one huge facade but also something
that I want to try with this is actually
making kind of a skyline now that met
that might sound very weird especially
when you're looking at all the sets that
I'm using like that spooky set and the
Alpine and medieval so it might seem
kind of weird to build a skyline with
that but without realizing it I actually
saw that my entrance somehow had a cool
skyline as well so I figured that I
might as well try and build a skyline
with some spooky stuff as well and see
how that comes out and if it really
turns out terrible that I might as well
remove it but if it turns out nice then
that's just something that I've done so
not to be cool and basically what I want
to take this is this whole park is kind
of inspired by anime stuff in the
general sense of things of course it's
it doesn't have to do too much with it
but the rides are somewhat themed to
some stuff and that might seem very
obvious and it's actually attack on
Titan where I got the idea to kind of
mix steampunk and medieval and people
were like no you don't do that and I was
like they do it in anime so might as
well though it's not really that
steampunk I just felt like it kind of
was with the 3d maneuver gear and the
general medieval kind of style that the
show had but somehow it had some modern
elements as well but basically I'm kind
of drifting off basically what I wanted
to do with this ride is something
extremely stupid which I don't know if
any of my subscribers actually know of
this but I've had a professor layton
yeah it's not really an obsession but
I've played it a lot in my life so I
figured that I would make something
that's kind of inspired by Professor
Layton now if
don't know professor professor layton
it's Japanese puzzle game and that's
basically it and you need to solve
puzzles and oh my god can it be annoying
at times because you get these same
music over and over again when solving
puzzles and you're gonna spend hours
while hundreds of hours possibly in the
game solving puzzles with the same music
over and over again on UTS so that music
is going to kill your brain as soon as
you hear it but also you'd walk around
with the storyline and look at the
scenery and be like that's nice a nice
story and all that and then suddenly
professor layton would go
mm that reminds me of a puzzle and then
you need to solve a puzzle and then
those things those moments are very
annoying but it's a fun game overall and
this one's kind of going to be based on
Professor Layton and the Curious Village
I think that's the title yeah and that's
a game that I've played a very long time
ago I think it's the first Professor
Layton game and basically what it was it
was a village that and I'm not going to
give any spoilers but in the middle of
the village that was this spooky kind of
tower and the tower and all kinds of
things sticking out of it and it nearly
seemed to just well disregard gravity
how do you even do that
yeah but that's kind of what it did so I
figured that I might as well try that as
well and try and get some near floating
parts of buildings and stuff sticking
out and just kind of make everything
crooks and all that it just kind of adds
to the spookiness of things but also to
the weird industrial steampunk feeling
so might as well so that's where I'm
going with this now of course I have no
clue if this is actually going to work
out or not and of course defying gravity
is not something that you can do in a
theme park so it'll be somewhat hard to
make things look like they are defying
gravity but make them look realistic at
the same time so I'll try to add some
supports and make it possible to
actually and enough way to things to
actually make them nearly float but of
course they're still gonna have to be
connected to buildings in some way some
ways and you can't make their building
quite as crooks as they were in
Professor Layton because safety measures
and theme parks and them all can't do
that though again this is an overdose or
park that's really some of the
things that I really like about just
deciding that you're Pike is going to be
over-the-top and somewhat unrealistic
though of course it has its boundaries
but you can just say well yeah no theme
park is going to build a leaning tower
and yeah though that might be true
this isn't over the top theme park and I
can just screw logic I'm just going to
do what I want
that's basically the attitude that I
want for this and that kind of works out
it's a bit of freedom that you get that
I really like to enjoy so yeah I am not
too sure about these pipes actually I
decided to add pipes because steampunk
and I know there are people out there I
like her lawyer you can't do you can't
just add pipes to a building to make it
steampunk that's not how it works
and I know that but I just wanted to get
that general atmosphere but I am not too
sure about the pipes but anyway that's
it for this episode so thanks for
watching and see you in the next one